another small town in America is
mourning the victims of a school
shooting and asking why it happened a
church held a vigil last night in Benton
Kentucky to honor those killed and
injured at Marshall County High School
yesterday
Bailey Holt and Preston cope died from
gunshot wounds
they were both 15 years old 14 other
students were wounded another four were
trampled and injured while trying to
escape a 15 year old suspect is in
custody now this is the latest of at
least 11 school shootings in this
country since January first Adriana Diaz
is in Benton which is 100 miles
northwest of Nashville with response to
this latest attack
Adriana good morning good morning the
shooting has shaken this close-knit
community of less than 5,000 people
police have yet to identify the shooter
or his motive but investigators
including the FBI and the ATF are trying
to figure out why this student walked
into a school and opened fire it still
doesn't feel real it doesn't feel like
it actually happened moments after
arriving at school teenagers were
scrambling for cover as their fellow
student began shooting it sounded like
there was a fight someone was hitting on
the window I took out my headphones and
turned around and everyone was just
broken up the school immediately went
into lockdown but some students had
already fled the grounds I took off I
started running you know I was scared
for my life
one student went back inside to rescue
her friend who was unharmed she's my
best friend I mean I can't lose her and
so we just we got her
police arrived to the school just seven
minutes after the first 9-1-1 call they
quickly found the gunman and arrested
him he was apprehended by the Sheriff's
Department here on site at the school
thankfully before any more lives could
be taken there's no way to know how much
farther it would have went buses
evacuated uninjured students to a nearby
middle school
frantic parents raced to the chaotic
scene hoping to find their children you
don't think it's gonna happen here you
know and like I said as soon as you hear
it it's terrifying five of the victims
were airlifted to Vanderbilt University
Medical Center in Nashville Preston Ryan
cope died at the hospital
Bailey Nicole holt was killed at the
scene they were both 15 Kentucky
governor Matt Bevin and this is a wound
that is going to take a long time to
heal and for some in this community will
never fully heal students say they'll
have trouble returning to the school
where their friends were killed there's
still be some fear like I can never look
at the school the same because I know
you know what happened there are still
five patients at Vanderbilt University
Medical Center all are expected to
survive the suspect will be charged with
two counts of murder and multiple counts
of attempted murder the county attorney
says those charges should come within
the next 48 hours and that he plans to
try the teen as an adult Nora
Adriana thank you